[dramatic synthetic music]
[deep tones]
[narrator]
Up until about 20 years ago
tiny computers,
smart phones, instant
messaging and video conferencing
were all fanciful science
fiction inventions.
Now they're so ubiquitous we
hardly give them
a second thought.
Most of these technologies are
good for mankind
but as with everything it
can be misused and turned
into nefarious tech that
can haunt us our entire lives.
[dramatic synthesized music]
[ominous music]
[disconcerting music]
In the past 50 years, technology
has leaped forward from the
transistor radio to cell phones
and satellite communication.
Weapons have advanced as well as
surveillance systems.
Today anyone can have
their 15 minutes of fame
just by streaming a video
of themselves worldwide.
We get our news instantly,
we can talk globally to anyone
and we have medical inventions
to make our lives better.
But in the hands of
scrupulous people these same
technologies can be used
to track our every move,
motivate us to vote in a
specific direction,
invade our bodies and spy on us.
We have become dependent on the
technologies we
take for granted
and those
technologies are poised
to take over the
world we live in
and perhaps make us their
minions.
[ominous music]
One of the most relevant
theories is that artificial
intelligence may one
day take over the world.
An AI takeover
is a hypothetical
scenario in which artificial
intelligence
becomes the dominant
form of intelligence on Earth.
With computers or
robots effectively taking the
control of the planet away
from the human species.
Possible scenarios
include replacement
of the entire human work force,
takeover by a super intelligent
AI
and the popular notion of a
robot uprising.
Some public figures
such as Stephen Hawking
and Elon Musk have
advocated research into
precautionary measures
to ensure future super
intelligent machines
remain under human control.
[ominous music]
The AI control problem
is the issue of how to
build a super intelligent
agent that will aid it's
creators and avoid
inadvertently building a
super intelligence that
will harm its creators.
Some scholars
argue that solutions
to the control problem might
also find applications
in existing
non-super intelligent AI.
Major approaches to the control
problem include alignment,
which aims to align AI goal
systems with human values
and capability control
which aims to reduce an AI's
systems capacity to harm
humans or gain control.
An example of capability control
is to research whether a super
intelligent AI could be
successfully
combined in an AI box.
According to Bostrom, such
capability control
proposals are not
reliable or
sufficient to solve the
control problem
in the long term
but may potentially
act as valuable
supplements to
alignment efforts.
Physicist Stephen Hawking,
Microsoft founder Bill
Gates and Space X founder
Elon Musk have expressed
concerns about the possibility
that AI could develop
to the point that humans
could not control it.
With Hawking
theorizing that this
could spell the end
of the human race.
[disconcerting music]
Stephen Hawking said in
2014 that success in creating
AI would be the biggest
event in human history.
Unfortunately it
might also be the last
unless we learn
how to avoid the risks.
Hawking believed that
in the coming decades,
AI could offer incalculable
benefits and risks.
Such as technology
outsmarting financial
markets,
out inventing human researchers,
out manipulating human
leaders and developing
weapons that we
cannot even understand.
In January 2015,
Nick Bostrom joined
Stephen Hawking,
Max Tegmark, Elon
Musk, Lord Martin Rees,
Jan Tullin
and numerous
other AI researchers
in signing the Future of Life
Institute's open
letter speaking to the
potential risks and
benefits associated
with artificial intelligence.
The signatories believe that
research on how to make AI
systems robust and beneficial
is both important and timely.
And that there are
concrete research
directions that can
be pursued today.
[intense ominous music]
[face paced dramatic music]
An autonomous car is a vehicle
that is capable of sensing
its environment and
navigating without human input
and many such vehicles are being
developed.
But as of May 2017 automated
cars permitted
on public roads are
not yet fully autonomous.
They all
require a human
driver at the wheel
who is ready at a moments notice
to take control of the vehicle.
Among one of the
the main obstacles to
widespread adoption of
autonomous vehicles are
concerns about the
resulting loss of driving
related jobs in the
road transport industry.
On March 18, 2018 the
first human was killed by an
autonomous vehicle in Arizona
by an Uber self driving car.
Self driving cars
combine a variety of
sensors to perceive
their surroundings,
such as radar,
lidar, sonar, gps,
odometry and inertial
measurement units.
Advanced control
systems interpret
sensory information to identify
appropriate
navigation paths as well
as obstacles and
relevant signage.
[tense music]
Connected vehicle platoons and
long distance
trucking are seen as
being at the
forefront of adopting
and implementing the technology.
PC Magazine defines
a self driving car as a
computer controlled
car that drives itself.
The Union of Concerned
Scientists states
that self driving cars
are cars or trucks in
which human drivers
are never required to
take control to safely
operate the vehicle.
Also known as autonomous
or driverless cars. They combine
sensors and software to control,
navigate and drive the vehicle.
[ominous music]
Possible technological
obstacles for
automated cars are
artificial intelligence
is still not able to
properly function
in chaotic inner
city environments.
A car's computer
could potentially be
compromised as
could a communication
system between cars. A car could
be hacked and
turned into a weapon.
Susceptibility of
car sensing and
navigation systems
to different types of
weather such as
snow or deliberate
interference,
included jamming and spoofing.
Avoidance of large
animals requires
recognition and
tracking and Volvo found
that software suited to caribou,
deer
and elk,
was ineffective with kangaroos.
Autonomous cars
may require very high
quality specialized
maps to operate properly.
Were these maps may be
out of date they would need
to be able to fall back
to reasonable behaviors.
[tense music]
Competition for the
radio spectrum desired
for the cars
communication is an issue.
Field programmability for the
systems will require careful
evaluation of
product development
and the component supply chain
and current road
infrastructure may need
changes for automated
cars to function optimally.
One may bring up the adage:
"Just because you can
do a thing doesn't mean
that you should do a thing."
People are wary of self driving
cars and often don't trust them.
Due to this and technology
factors, we may be a long way
off from seeing a day
when all cars are self driving.
[upbeat music]
In science fiction we often see
the use of nanotechnology.
Tiny robots that can
enter the body and
repair cells or accomplish
cures to a disease.
But nano particles
have been around
since the 50's and
recent advancements
makes this something we will see
more of today and in the future.
There are several dangers with
this kind of technology, though.
Nano particles are likely to be
dangerous for
three main reasons.
Nano particles may damage the
lungs.
We know that the ultra fine
particles from diesel machines,
power
plants and
incinerators can cause
considerable damage
to human lungs.
This is both because
of their size as they
can get deep
into the lungs, and also
because they carry
other chemicals including
metals and
hydrocarbons in with them.
Nano particles can get
into the body through
the skin,
lungs and digestive system.
This may help create
free radicals which
can cause cell damage
and damage to the DNA.
There's also concern that
once nano particles are in the
bloodstream they'll be able to
cross the blood-brain barrier.
The human body has
developed a tolerance to most
naturally occurring elements
and molecules that it
has contact with. It has
no natural immunity to new
substances and is more
likely to find them toxic.
There's also the introduction of
nano particles
or technology that
could be injected
into person allowing
other technologies
to track them.
These particles can also be
sprayed or introduced into the
environment on
the battle field to
track whole armies,
or attack them.
The particles then may harm
anyone in that environment.
Though there are
positive uses for
nanotechnology such
as in the medical field,
the introduction of
any foreign technology
into the body can
be very dangerous.
Vaccines with nanotechnology
may attack a virus but
also harm healthy cells
within the body or may be used
to track the individual who
accepted the vaccine that
can be triggered to make
you get sick, even kill you.
Nanotechnology is already
a huge industry with billions
of dollars being spent on
research and development
worldwide. There's still a
great deal to learn about
both the potential benefits
and risks of the technology.
Nevertheless, most
experts agree that the use of
nano technology in electronics,
the pharmaceutical
industry and in areas
such as medical imaging is
outstripping our
understanding of the OHS risks.
Nano technology
could lead to significant
developments in medicine,
manufacturing
and computing.
However it may also
bring significant
new health hazards.
[disconcerting music]
[tense music]
Tracking American
citizens has become
a major issue in the past decade
with the emergence
of drones both
in the military and
corporate world.
At almost any given time,
wherever you are it is likely a
camera is recording your
movements, especially in a city.
The combination of
surveillance drones and
facial recognition has
made this much easier.
Even commercial toy
drones have the ability
to follow you simply
by looking at you.
Drones have been used to
intentionally cause harm.
It's the most
dangerous because they're
the bad actors that have
nefarious intentions.
Drones are being
used for illicit
activities which include but are
not limited to
transport of illegal
drugs,
dropping leaflets into NFL
stadiums,
dropping contraband such
as drugs, cell phones,
cigarettes
and weapons into prison yards.
And
in some cases carrying weapons.
In one case a drone
helped an inmate
escape from a
correctional facility.
To further validate
concerns the US military has
identified a number of
ways that commercial off the
shelf drones have been
weaponized with intentions to
attack US war fighters or
military bases over seas.
There are two other
complications when it comes to
addressing potential
drone threats. First, there's
a combination of 21
federal rules and regulations
prohibiting the use of
counter drone technology.
The second issue is
that, until recently, drones
were not required to be
registered and there is a
large number of unregistered
drones which make it
extremely difficult to
identify the drone pilot.
This is especially
important to identify
friend from foe.
Additionally there is
no single counter drone
technology that addresses
all the various
drone technologies.
One obvious consideration
is understanding
the implications of taking down
a drone while flying
over people and
the possible injury
to those people.
Drones can also be
used to spy on you and
combined with other
technologies such as
listening devices
and IR scanners, they
can watch you and
record your movements.
Every new technology
comes with the possibility of
being used for undesirable
or dangerous purposes.
The future of drones
will require a balance of
enabling drones for good,
countering drones for
bad and a comprehensive air
traffic management system
that encompasses manned
and unmanned aircraft.
[dramatic music]
[upbeat music]
Protesters in Hong Kong
are taking extraordinary
measures to protect
their identities.
That's because
facial recognition
technologies in China have been
used to surveil
and detain people
suspected of
crimes in the region.
Having their faces being
recognized by cameras
could have devastating
consequences for protesters.
These protesters
are using various
techniques to throw
off facial recognition
cameras,
including lasers that the
cameras can't
process or recognize.
Full coverage gas
masks and ear wear.
They have put up
umbrellas around
cameras to block
them and even torn
down facial recognition towers.
Facial recognition is a
polarizing topic
and is sometimes
seen as a problematic
development
in surveillance capitalism.
People generally don't give
permission or even
know they're being
tracked. They also don't know
how their faces are being used.
For example, when you
walk into most retail stores
there is a security camera
there to ward off theft.
However, that camera could be
doing much more than warding
off theft. It could use your
face for other databases so
the store can market to you
and build a behavior profile
that links your
in-store activity
with your online activity.
Think about how Amazon
built its facial recognition
technology. It curated photos
of your online profiles and your
shopping experiences as well
as images from its Ring Doorbell
security application and
put together a profile of you.
So is security worth giving up
your privacy?
The problem is that
facial recognition
software is calibrated
to white men, therefore
it misidentifies
people of color and
especially women of
color at alarming rates.
Increasing the risk
that certain groups
will be incorrectly
associated with crimes.
Currently there
are no transparent
rules on how facial
recognition data can
be used and how
it can be shared. In
some cases it has
been ruled as lawful.
It's a lot to hand over your
face to unlimited entities
who have not figured out
the rules for using that data.
We may never reach the
place where our faces determine
our social standing,
as is the case in Hong Kong but
will it determine our credit
ratings? Our job prospects?
These are degrees of invasion
that are still possible.
It's time to protect
your privacy
like you were
protesting against an
authoritarian government.
Think of
it as if your life
and the lives of
your family and
friends depends on
it.
Not to suggest you walk around
with masks on all
day but be more
diligent about what
you post online.
Share photos and
videos of family
and friends on a secure network,
understand that
when you buy personal
assistant devices
you're giving up
intimate details
about your self,
your family and your friends,
and you
have no transparency
on how those
intimate details are
being shared or used.
Put covers on your
device cameras and only
uncover them when
you're using the camera.
You can't stop cameras
from picking up your face and
storing it but you can take
control whenever possible.
Businesses and organizations
also have an obligation
to their users and customers
to protect their rights.
Privacy is one of those
fundamental rights, one that we
should enjoy in
our digital world
as well as in our physical one.
Without the protection
of those rights around
technology like facial
recognition, we may end
up in a place both as
businesses and individuals
where there is no
escape from surveillance
and that sort of
dystopia is not the
world we
want to live in.
[upbeat music]
There should be
more regulation around
facial recognition
and both as individuals
and organizations
we should be fighting
against improper usage
of facial recognition.
Get behind some of
the facial recognition
legislation that is being
proposed. One example
is the Commercial
Facial Recognition Privacy
Act of 2019,
proposed in Washington, DC.
In which would prohibit
commercial users of
facial recognition
technology from collecting
and re-sharing data
for identifying or
tracking customers
without their consent.
Microsoft president
Brad Smith has
spoken out in
support of the bill.
In the meantime, in the absence
of solid laws,
opt for privacy and
be transparent about the way
you allow
the use of your data.
[upbeat music]
[disconcerting music]
Have you been chipped?
Implementing chips in
humans has privacy and security
implications that go well
beyond cameras in public places.
Facial recognition, tracking of
our locations,
our driving habits,
our spending histories and even
beyond ownership of your data.
This topic touches
upon your hand, your
heart, your brain and the
rest of your body. Literally.
This new development is
set to give a very different
meaning to hacking
the body or bio hacking.
While cyber experts
continue to worry
about protecting
critical infrastructure
and mitigating
security risks that could
harm the economy
or cause a loss of life.
Implanted chips also
effect health but add in new
dimensions that conflict
with people's religious beliefs.
RFID microchips embedded under
the skin with a procedure
that's already
cheap and available,
provide a digital
interface to the
real world,
centered about the holders
identity,
credit card information,
bus pass,
library card and many other
sources of information
you currently
carry in your purse or wallet.
And it can instead be stored on
an RFID chip under your skin.
[disconcerting sounds]
However getting chipped
could be a way to control
you. When guns are paired
to the chips in their owners,
revolutionary heroes can
no longer break into their
oppressors arsenal to turn
their firepower against them.
Putting so much
importance on a device
only available
to those that seek
it out requires
keeping close tabs on
its availability
and affordability.
If the advantages effectively
disadvantage those who
choose not to participate,
gaps between classes may widen.
In a world controlled
entirely by chips
within your skin,
its possible that hackers
and evil doers could
scan and replicate
the data on your
chips onto their own,
effectively replacing your
physical presence which is
notably different from just
stealing digital credentials.
Every Hollywood
movie has taught us that
implanted microchips
are primarily for big
brother,
governments and corporations to
continuously track
our every whereabouts.
This is a real concern that
needs to be handled with privacy
controls and good security
practices from the get go.
In a world where you
purchase food with
a chip in your
hand, it's not hard to
think that some
people might prefer
to use a card in
their wallet instead.
However, it's also not hard to
imagine a world in which
the benefits of a microchip
mandate its usage.
Basically requiring
everyone to receive a
microchip, or starve,
lose their job, etcetera.
[ominous music]
One of the benefits
of a microchip is
it's invisible to those
who don't know
about it. Making it
harder for thieves and
adversaries to steal
your information.
However this advantage
is a double edged sword
when you consider that
people could potentially
be oblivious to microchips,
implanted by others
in themselves while
sleeping or unconscious.
[tense upbeat music]
Biblical apocalyptics
claim it could be the mark of
the beast indicating the
beginning of revelations.
There is currently no
government agency that
oversees or controls
neuro-electric interface
enhancements, with the
closest body
being the FDA due to
its broad jurisdiction
over medical devices.
The long term health risks
of implanting microchips
in humans is relatively unknown.
On one hand
human micro chipping
has been green lighted
around the world by
various authoritative
bodies,
including the FDA in America.
[tense upbeat music]
[upbeat tribal drum beat]
It may seem we live in a science
fiction world,
after all we have a space
station in orbit.
We've been to the
moon and new
advanced satellites bring
us information from
around the planet.
But that world
could turn out to be
a dystopian empire
where the population
is controlled and
herded in line.
At the conclusion of the
June 1992 United Nations
Conference on Environment and
Development in Rio de Janeiro,
Brazil. President George H.
W. Bush and the leaders of
177 other nations signed a
document known as agenda 21.
At the time it was seen
as a perfectly sensible
planning paper.
A non-binding statement
of intent aimed at
dealing with sustainability
on an increasingly
crowded planet.
But
in the 22 years since that day,
at the hands of
groups like the John
Birch society,
Agent 21 has been
transformed in
much of the American
public's mind into
a secret plot to
impose a totalitarian
world government.
A nefarious effort
to crush freedom
in the name of environmentalism.
Some say Agenda 21 will
lead to a new Dark Ages
of pain and misery yet
unknown to mankind. It is
a comprehensive plan of
utopian environmentalism,
social engineering and
global political control.
The most dangerous threat
to America's sovereignty
yet and technology
will make it possible.
It will make our nation
a vassal of the UN,
result in the destruction
of our lives, force
rural areas,
populations to be decimated and
lead to having 90% of the
population murdered.
The end these
critics all agree will be the
imposition of a collectivist
world government.
Several politicians are
aware of the agenda with
state and local authorities
passing legislation
to ban it. The list of
fears include one-world
currency, one religion if any,
one military, no
private property,
no family units, mandatory
vaccines, microchips
for everyone, social credit
systems, 5G monitoring
and the government raising
your children and
controlling all the schools.
People would not be able to own
cars or businesses as everything
will be managed either by
corporations or governments.
[upbeat disconcerting music]
In an Agenda 21 world
you would have to be
micro chipped so the
technology could track
you. What you buy
and where you go would
depend on your
compliance with the agenda.
Technology would
track your every
move with facial recognition,
microchips, drones and other
sophisticated tracing science.
All of the technology needed
to do this is already in play
now with more new technologies
being developed every year.
We are all moving
toward a one-world
government faster than
previously predicted.
The increasing use of
drones for commercial
purposes has become
one of the biggest emerging
threats to the future of
airplane safety according
to Allianz Global
Corporate and Specialty.
The expected rise in the
use of drones or unmanned
aerial vehicles for a host
of different applications may
leave operators exposed
to a whole new set of risks
including third party
damage or injury and liability.
One of the biggest risks, it
said, was
from radio frequency
interference
resulting in loss of control and
in worse case scenario,
fatalities.
Other problems include
invasion or privacy,
aerial surveillance
and data collection.
Privacy advocates
contend that with drones, the
government will be able
to engage in widespread
pervasive surveillance
because drones are cheaper
to operate than their
manned counterparts.
Drones are being used
by law enforcement
and border control surveillance
teams in case
of essential supplies,
however, drones are
not being used
exclusively by good guys.
In case of natural disasters,
search and rescue teams employ
them to gather information,
or to drop essential supplies.
However, drones are not being
used exclusively by good guys.
Bad guys are leveraging
drones to achieve
their malicious objectives,
being
easy to control, drones can be
used to perform
different attacks.
The reliance on
wireless communications
make drones
vulnerable to various
attacks. These attacks can have
drastic effects
including commercial
and non-commercial losses.
In this
context there is
a lack of proper
understanding on
how hackers perform
their attacks and
hijack a drone
in order to intercept
it or even crash it. In
fact, drones can also be
compromised for malicious
purposes hence there
is a need to detect them
and prevent them from
causing any damage.
With a drone you could be
followed anywhere and tracked,
military drones are already
being deployed on the
battlefield for surveillance.
It would be a simple
step to bring them home
and use them to track citizens.
In August of 2018 a drone
led assassination attempt was
foiled when two drones wrapped
with explosives were used
to assassinate the Venezuelan
President. They were shot
down by snipers, injuring
eight soldiers and one civilian.
Actually, drones
are being used by
insurgents and terrorists alike.
Drones were used by ISIS to drop
bombs and to film
propaganda videos in
conflict zones such
as the targeting
of Iraq and Syrian
military personnel.
Being quiet and performing
at altitude, you would
never know if you were
being observed by a drone.
Justification for
surveillance of citizens
are in court cases
now around the country.
[tense somber music]
[upbeat high pitched music]
Many futuristic weapons
are already being
used on the battlefield today.
The military
is always poised for
advanced weapons
systems and developing
new weapons yearly.
The XM-25 grenade launcher is
equipped with a laser
range finder and
on board computer. It packs a
magazine of four
25mm projectiles and
programs them
to detonate as they
pass by their targets.
That feature
will allow soldiers to strike
enemies who
are taking cover.
By 2012 the army has armed
every infantry squad and
special forces unit with at
least one of the big guns.
In August a lucky
soldier got to pull
the trigger and fire
off an HEAB high
explosive air burst
round at the Aberdeen
testing ground in Maryland.
Those
projectiles pack quiet a punch.
They
were purposely 300%
more effective than
normal ammo and
will be able to strike
targets as far as
2300 feet away.
Remotely operated weapons are
showing up everywhere. Israel is
building an automated kill zone.
An American firm,
Moore Industries,
offers turret that can aim and
fire two automatic shotguns.
Some
robots have been
defusing bombs for
years but none have seen combat.
According to Lieutenant General
Rick Lynch who believes that 122
men could have been spared if
combat robots had been working.
There was a set of armed robots
sent to Iraq. They never fired
a shot, however. They weren't
allowed to.
No one could guarantee
that the robots
wouldn't go berserk
and mow down friendly troops
or otherwise malfunction even
though they have
lots of safeguards.
Considering how much
firepower they pack, safeguards
are really important.
The MARS system can be
equipped with four grenade
launchers and a machine
gun that packs 400 rounds
of 7.62 caliber ammunition.
But it's manufacturers like to
point out its less
lethal capabilities.
Instead of mowing
people down, it
can stick to the
fine print of the
first law of
robotics and fire tear
gas canisters,
smoke grenades, smoke
bombs and perhaps
even tasers upcoming
40mm people zapper projectile.
Three were deployed in Iraq last
year.
The active denial
system fires a beam
of millimeter wave radiation.
It makes
people feel like
their skin is burning
without causing any
permanent damage.
Though promising as
a nonlethal weapon,
the pain rate has
some serious limits.
On a rainy day
water droplets will
disperse the beam
and it may feel warm and
refreshing instead
of frightening, on a
hot day the cooling
system might give out.
The problems don't stop there.
Ratheon's
baby is bulky and
despite repeated
requests to send it
into battle, shipments
of the energy weapon
have been delayed.
The military is looking for a
strong lighter weapon.
[laid back music]
If troops spot someone
suspicious approaching them,
they can
use the long range acoustic
device to send a
warning message.
It fires narrow beams of
sound waves that can be heard
clearly from about 1000 feet
away. Crank up the power and
it can emit a warning tone
so loud that anyone in its
path would have no choice
but to cover their ears and run.
The manufacturer
doesn't like to call these
devices weapons even
though they've been used
to repel pirates.
Cops used them to harass
protesters at the G20
summit in Pittsburgh.
Drones are arguably the most
controversial
weapon in the war on
terror. By some accounts they
are deeply feared
by the Taliban.
They've taken out
Al-Qaeda and Taliban
leaders and their sound
when flying low is a
constant annoyance
and reminder of their
menace. But they also
kill a lot of civilians.
They are, however, far
more cost effective than
supersonic fighter jets.
Predators can pack two Hell
Fire missiles. Their big
brothers, Reapers, can hold
four Hell Fires and up
to two 500 pound bombs.
Flash bang grenades
were designed to stun
people but they have a
pretty bad safety record.
The little bombs have
dismembered at least one
soldier and caused
hearing loss in others.
To remedy that problem, Mark
Grubelich and his colleagues
at Sandia National Laboratory
built the improved flash bang
grenade. It hurls flaming
aluminum particles into the air
causing a bright flash without
an accompanying shock wave.
Even the angriest
mobs would probably
think twice about
trying to pass a
taser shock wave barrier.
It's the less
lethal equivalent
of a claymore mine.
Push the big red button
and it will fire 24 electrified
probes at the same
time in a single direction.
After learning about an
experimental
weapon that can make
people feel seasick, Limor Fried
and Phil Torrone
more decided to
build their own. They did it
for less than $250 dollars and
wrote step by step instructions
so anyone can make one at home.
It can cause a nauseating light
show with 36 pulsating LED's.
Now if you're worried
that someones about
to attack you, but
not completely sure of
their intent,
it's a good idea to give
them a warning before
pulling the trigger.
Green laser pointers are a great
way to extend that courtesy.
The marines like to call them
ocular interruption devices.
Shine one in someone's
face and your target should
immediately get the message
that it's time to back off.
The LA9P made by B.
E. Meyers can warn
people from up to 2
and a half miles away.
It fires a 250 milliwatt beam.
That's roughly one fourth the
strength smallest
anti-aircraft lasers.
Even so, you've got
to be careful when
handling the thing.
Over a few months
in Iraq,
a dozen soldiers were
wounded in
dazzler friendly fire.
Several troops may
have been injured
while monkeying
around with laser target
disintegrators which
are substantially
more powerful than
the less lethal devices.
And behold the Laser Avenger.
A cannon that can be used
to take down incoming
enemy aircraft. Boeing was able
to shoot a drone down out of
the sky with a Hummer mounted
laser even though it's not
particularly high powered.
It cooked the
remote control aircraft
using a somewhat
feeble one-kilowatt beam.
More recently, the company
shot down another UAV using
a low-powered laser
paired with its mobile active
targeting resource for
integrated experiments or
matrix system during a test
in White Sands, New Mexico.
Northrop Grumman
is hard at work on
a 100 kilowatt
laser weapon which
could do far more
damage but it's
not quiet ready for prime time.
It's fully operational but looks
like a refrigerator.
Boeing announced
in December that the
Avenger has been used
to destroy 50 different
improvised explosive devices
during tests at
Redstone Arsenal in Huntsville,
Alabama.
[upbeat music]
[disconcerting music]
Science fiction has always been
a median for futuristic
imagination. And while
different colored aliens and
intergalactic
travel are yet to be
discovered, there is an array of
technologies that are no longer
figments of the
imagination thanks
to the world of science fiction.
Some of the creative inventions
that have appeared
in family favorite
movies like Back
to the Future and
Total Recall are
now at the forefront
of modern technology.
While exploring space,
characters such as Captain
Kirk and Spock would come across
alien life who spoke a different
language.
To understand the galactic
foreigners the Star
Trek characters
used a device that immediately
translated the aliens'
unusual language.
Star Trek's Universal
Communicator
was first seen on
screen as Spock
tampered with it in
order to communicate
with a non-biological entity.
Although the idea
in Star Trek was to
communicate with
intelligent alien life, a device
capable of breaking
down language barriers
would revolutionize
real time communication.
Now products such
as SourceNex Pocket
Talk and Skype's
new voice translation
services are
capable of providing
instantaneous translation
between languages.
Flawless real-time communication
is far off but the technological
advancements
over the last decade
mean this feat is within reach.
The idea behind
beaming someone up was
that a person could
be broken down into
an energy form and
then converted
back into matter
at their destination.
Transporting people
this way on Star
Trek's USS Enterprise
had been around
since the very beginning of the
series,
debuting in the pilot episode.
Scientists haven't figured
out how to transport humans
yet but they can teleport
balls of energy known
as photons. In this case
teleportation is based
on a phenomenon know
as quantum entanglement.
This refers to a condition
in quantum mechanics where
two entangled
particles may be very far from
one another yet remain
connected so that actions
performed on one effect the
other regardless of distance.
The information exchange
between the two photons occurs
at least 10,000 times
faster than the speed of light.
Not long into the first Star
Wars movie, Obi-Wan Kenobi
receives a holographic message.
By definition, a hologram is
a 3D image created from the
interference of
light beams from a
laser onto a 2D surfaces and
can only be seen in one angle.
In 2018, researchers from
Brigham Young University
in Utah created a real hologram.
Their technique
called volumetric display
works like an Etch-a-Sketch
toy but uses
particles at high speeds.
With lasers, researchers can
trap particles and move them
into a designated shape while
another set of lasers emit red,
green and blue light into the
particle and create an image.
But so far this can only happen
on extremely small scales.
After losing his
hand Luke Skywalker
receives a bionic
version that has all the
functions of a normal hand.
This scenario
is now more feasible
than the previous one.
Researchers from the
Georgia University of
Technology in Atlanta,
Georgia have been developing a
way for amputees
to control each of their
prosthetic fingers using
an ultra sonic sensor.
In the movie Skywalker's
prosthesis uses electromagnetic
sensors attached to his muscles.
The sensors
can be switched into different
modes and are controlled
by the flexing or
contracting of his muscles.
The prosthesis
created by the Georgia
Tech researchers,
however, uses machine
learning and ultra
sound signals to
detect fine finger
by finger movement.
Orbiting Earth in 2001 a
Space Odyssey is Space
Station V,
a large establishment located in
low Earth orbit where
astronauts can bounce
around in micro gravity.
Does this sound familiar?
The Space Station V
provided inspiration for
the International
Space Station which has
been orbiting the Earth
since 1998 and currently
accommodates up to
6 astronauts at a time.
Although Space Station V
appears much more luxurious
the ISS has accomplished
much more science.
The ISS has been
fundamental in microgravity
research since the start
of its construction in 1998.
Tablets are wonderful hand
held computers that can
be controlled at the press
of a finger. These handy
devices are used by people
across the globe and even
further upwards in the
International Space Station.
Apple claims to
have invented the
tablet with the
release of its iPad.
However, Samsung
made an extremely
interesting case
in court that Apple
was wrong.
Stanley Kubrick and Sir
Arthur C. Clarke did it by
including the device in the
in the movie "2001:
A Space Odyssey"
released in 1968. In the film,
Dr. David Bowman and Dr. Frank
Poole watch news updates from
their flat screen computers
which they called news pads.
Samsung claimed that these news
pads were the original tablet
featured in a film
over 40 years before
the first iPad arrived in 2010.
[curious music]
We may even be
closer to an actual warp
drive for space travel.
An ion thruster
or ion drive is
a form of electric
propulsion used for
space craft propulsion.
It creates thrust
by accelerating
ions using electricity.
This engine was
used on Deep Space
One and the Dawn
NASA spacecraft.
A plasma propulsion engine
is a type of electric propulsion
that generates thrust from
a quasi-neutral plasma.
While most plasma engines are
still confined to
the laboratory,
some have been actively flying
and used on missions.
As of 2011, NASA
partnered with the aerospace
company Busek and
launched the first Hall Effect
thruster, aboard the
TacSat-2 satellite. The
thruster was the satellite's
main propulsion system.
Actual warp drive is
still far into the future,
but as more of these
advanced propulsion
systems are developed,
the idea is not only
feasible but now we know
it can actually be done.
[dramatic sounds]
Shrouded in mystery,
the existence of a secret
space program is a
closely guarded secret.
But information from government
whistle blowers, intelligence
operatives,
and former astronauts
have been surfacing for decades.
In 2020,
America launched the Space
Force,
a new branch of the US Military.
Along with the Air Force
the new Space Force will
be in charge of all military
needs in outer space.
Many question the need for such
a program.
We already had the Space Command
department of the Air Force.
Some speculate
the need may be a
fear of extra terrestrial
invasion or influence
on the planet.
[eery sounds]
Technology already exists
for the new space force to take
over. For example, the X37B
Space Plane is now in use.
Much like the old
space shuttles, the X37B
can be tasked with
several secret missions.
Though it is unmanned, or so we
are told.
The strange thing
about this space
plane, is that its
mission is top secret.
No one apart from a tiny
handful of top military
experts know what the
aircraft is tasked to do.
What we do know
is that the aircraft,
also known as an
orbital test vehicle,
will deploy a
satellite into orbit and
also test power
beaming technology.
The small plane is unmanned,
which
means there are no astronauts
on board the vehicle. It is
controlled remotely from Earth.
It is able to fly back down to
Earth and land
on a runway like a
standard airplane. Meaning it
can be re-launched
over and over.
The pentagon,
a top military building where
America's most
senior military officials
work,
has revealed very few details
about the aircraft's
missions in the past.
Although it is
often referred to as
a spy plane,
the US Air Force has
never confirmed if the rocket is
monitoring other
countries or satellites.
Some experts have
previously said it would
be difficult to monitor
other satellites. It
should be noted also
that China has a secret
space vehicle but
little is known about it.
We may never know what the
secret mission really is.
But the secret space program
goes much deeper than
just one spy plane.
Rumors have persisted
for decades that the
USA has such a program.
Allegedly it began
after the Roswell incident,
when America
came into possession
of alien technology.
There are those who claim
we have
already been to the moon
in the 1950's and
the NASA program
was only for public consumption.
Whistle blowers
have said we have
time travel technology,
we've been
to Mars and there is even a base
on the moon and Mars.
Further down the rabbit hole,
is rumors that we
actually fought
a war with aliens,
and the secret space program is
in place to protect
us from them.
With Russian inspector
satellites largely
believed to be
orbital weapons platforms
and China now beginning to field
its own maneuverable unmanned
orbital platforms that can
also be used to disrupt our
nation's satellite capabilities,
it's clear today
the United States is
finding ways to fight
future wars in space.
At least as far as
non-classified programs go.
[dramatic music]
Despite harsh statements made
by both Russian and Chinese
government officials
regarding America's space force.
Each of those nations
has already maintained
space based branches
of their own for years.
In fact, even
America once had a secretive
Department of
Defense space program
complete with its own military
astronauts.
A 3.3 billion California based
space port
meant for secretive
space shuttle
launches into polar
orbit and more.
The Endeavor was called the
manned space flight engineer
program, and although it
hasn't gotten much attention
in the years since,
the pentagon invested billions
of dollars into it throughout
the 1970's and 80's.
A secret group of
32 men was selected
from the U.S. Air Force
and trained as
astronauts completely
independent of
their peers at NASA.
The specialized
training revolved
around deploying
classified payloads
and conducting other secretive
activities in orbit
using America's
space shuttle as
the primary orbital
platform. In fact, at one time,
the DOD intended to fly more
shuttle flights per
year than NASA.
[laid back music]
Black Star is the reported
codename of a secret
United States orbital
space plane system.
The possible existence of the
Black Star program was reported
in March of 2006 by Aviation
Week and Space Technology
magazine.
The magazine reported that the
program had been under way since
at least the early
1990's and that
the impetus for Black Star was
to allow the United
States government
to retain orbital reconnaissance
capabilities
jeopardized following
the 1986 Challenger disaster.
The article also said
the United States Air
Force Space Command
was unaware of Black Star.
Suggesting it was
operated by an intelligence
agency or some other
secret space program.
Aviation Week
speculated that such a
space craft could
also have offensive
military capabilities. A concept
colloquially known
as the space bomber.
The magazine also
stated that it was likely
that Black Star
would be moth balled,
although it is
unclear whether this is
due to a cost or
failure of the program.
[dramatic music]
A secret space
program was revealed
to the worldwide
public following
allegations against
Gary McKinnon for
hacking the US Defense
programs in 2002.
In an interview televised
on the BBC, McKinnon
stated that he was
able to get into the
military's network simply
by using a computer
code familiar to
computer administrators.
In his interview
with the BBC he also
stated of the disclosure
project that "They
are some very credible
relied upon people
all saying yes. There
is UFO technology.
There's anti-gravity,
there's free
energy and it's
extra terrestrial
in origin and they've
captured space
craft and reverse
engineered it."
He said he investigated a
NASA photographic expert's claim
that at the Johnson Space
Center's building 8, images were
regularly cleaned of evidence
of UFO craft and he confirmed
this comparing the raw originals
with the processed images.
He stated to have
viewed a detailed image of
something not man made
and cigar shaped, floating
above the northern hemisphere
and assuming his viewing
would be undisrupted
owing to the hour, he did
not think of capturing
the image because he was
bedazzled and therefore
did not think of securing
it with a screen capture
function in the software
at the point his
connection was interrupted.
McKinnon described the
cigar shaped space craft in
rudimentary terms but
with some notable features
that paralleled other
witnesses description of
an existing cylindrical
space craft.
[tense music]
One of the most
interesting things about this
was a Microsoft Excel
spreadsheet he came
across with 20-30 names
of government officials
that was titled
"Non-terrestrial officers".
What's more intriguing,
according to reports McKinnon
also discovered an unusual
list of US Navy vessels.
But cross checking against the
active list of
surface ships and
submarines, McKinnon
could not find those
names on the current
US Navy roster.
What does this mean?
The list of non-terrestrial
officers is alleged by
many UFO researchers
to be the names of US
Navy and Air Force
officers who are serving
on ships off the Earth.
That's to say they are assigned
to interplanetary vessels.
Additionally, the names of
the ships that he found are
actually the names
of interplanetary
spaceships currently in service.
[tense music]
Is it possible we have an active
interplanetary space force
already being utilized for
the protection of the Earth?
We certainly have
the technology to build and
maintain such a force.
The key would
be in the billions
allocated to the
dark military budget in the USA.
With enough money,
you could build several
fleets and the black
budget has plenty.
[ominous music]
Technology has the
power to do many things
and changing the
world is one of them.
We're privileged to live in a
time where
science and
technology can assist us,
make our lives
easier and rethink
the ways we go
about our daily lives.
The technology we're already
exposed and accustomed
to has paved the way for
us to innovate further and
this list of current and
future technologies certainly
have the potential to
change our lives even more.
We may even be
closer to that flying
car you were
promised as a child.
They do exist today.
However,
with all innovations it
will depend on what
we do with them.
They can either enhance
our lives and make the
world a better place to live
or we may find ourselves
in a dystopian future
where we are ruled and
controlled by the very
technologies we rely on.
That is up to us and
how we manage an ever
changing world with
advanced technology.
[ominous music]